c'est une autorisation exceptionnelle
qu'ont réussi à obtenir un alpes et 10
rb titouane relaté le quotidien des
enquêteurs de la brigade criminelle au
coeur du mythique 36 quai des orfèvres
pendant quatre mois l'histoire commence
par une séance de dédicace de leur
premier ouvrage enquête général à la
brigade de répression du banditisme dans
cette séance dédicace c'est arrivé le
patronat brigade criminelle qui est
surnommé dans le milieu monsieur non
parce qu'ils refusent tous les projets
il veut pas voir un journaliste dans son
service et par jeu et par provocation
lui a dit alors quand est ce que nous a
accueillis chez vous en étant persuadé
qu'ils diraient non et il a dit quand
vous voulez voilà donc
l'invitation était trop belle et puis on
a accepté en
on est parti plusieurs semaines là-bas
la crim créée en 1912 est toujours
considéré comme le plus prestigieux des
services de police judiciaire landru le
docteur petiot guy georges une histoire
faite de grandes affaires criminelles et
denquête souvent longues et difficiles
des photos une documentation très riche
d enregistrement c'est ce que fournit
rénale titouane pour rythmer le récit de
cette immersion avec ses aquarelles
ça m'arrive assez souvent de lui
demander des photos en particulier parce
que effectivement quand on me disait
tout à l'heure quand je fais le
découpage de mes pages je travaille
exclusivement avec le texte au départ
pour décider du rythme des pages et je
décide enfin en fait je mets sur le
papier une proposition d'illustration et
ensuite je compare avec la documentation
de choses soient si je vais pouvoir le
faire ou pas et l'exercice est toujours
deux ans parce que des fois il ya des
choses que je trouve pas et que je
repère des fois il ya des trucs que je
trouve que j'avais pas prévu et qui sont
parfois je tombe sur une de ces photos
je me dis ah ça il faut absolument je le
met
voilà et du coup le le découpage bouge
sans arrêt ce qui nous intéressait
c'était de s'affranchir de tout ce qu'on
véhicule à travers
les séries télé mais mes documentaires
un peu
tapageur et au nom raconte on essaye en
tout cas de retranscrire même ce qui
ressemble à de l'ennui de la tente des
périodes de latence
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment important
de pouvoir raconter ça aussi l'escalier
mythique du 36 quai des orfèvres et ses
148 marche appartiendront bientôt au
passé car la crim déménagera en 2017 aux
batignolles raynal pellicer et it one
aimerait bien continuer leur immersion
du côté de la justice
les assises ou le service après vente
comme on dit allez crime